وفي ملف اخر اندلع حريق كبير في مستودع
بمنطقه هامبورج شمالي المانيا في وقت مبكر
من صباح اليوم وافادت وسائل اعلام المانيا
انه جرى تصنيف الوضع في المدينه بانه شديد
الخطوره بسبب امكانيه تاثر السكان من
الغازات الناجمه عن الحريق الذي لم تعرف
اسبابه بعد ونقلت تقارير صحفيه عن متحدث
باسم رجال الاطفاء قوله ان اجواء وسط
مدينه هامبورغ معتمه وادى الحريق الكبير
في المستودع الى اغلاق خطوط السكك
الحديديه الواصله بين هامبرغ ومدن مجاوره
وتاجيل مسارات رحله اخرى
معنا الان من برلين مراسلنا عيسى الطيبي
اذا عيسى ضعنا في سوره اخر التفاصيل تفضل
السلطات الرسميه في هامبورغ قالت بان هذا
الحريق اندلع الساعه الرابعه واربعين
دقيقه صباح هذا اليوم وبانه اندلع في
منطقه في مكان صغير ثم فتى ينتشر بين
المستودعات التخزين مستودعات التخزين
الكيميائيه المجاوره
الحادث وقع في شمال الشرق مدينه هامبورغ
وهذا الامر ادى لتكوين سحابه كيميائيه
ضخمه كما قالت هيئه هيئه الاطفاء وبانها
اتجهت الان نحو وسط المدينه الشرطه
الالمانيه تحدثت عن اجلال نحو 140 مواطنا
في المنطقه لكنها لا الى غايه هذه اللحظه
لا تعرف مدى خطوره هذا الامر خصوصا ان بعض
المصادر تتحدث عن وجود ماده كبريت
الهيدروجين ايضا تحدثت هيئه الاطفاء
والدفاع المدني بوجود 200 فرقه اطفاء في
عين المكان المتحدث باسم الدفاع المدني في
هامبرغال بان هذه المهمه غير اعتياديه
وشاقه وبان الامر الان
يعني ينصب في التركيز على اطفاء الحريق
ومن ثم تدخل الشرطه لاجراء تحقيقاتها
لمعرفه ماذا جرى الامر الاخر هو ان هذا
الحريق مسعيد قطاعات واسعه في المدينه
نتحدث عن قطع خطوط الاتصالات البريه عن
طريق القطارات بين هذه الولايه ولايه
هامبورغ وولايه
وايضا قطع خطوط القطارات بين روستوك شمالي
المانيا وبين هامبورج اما الخطوط الاخرى
المتبقيه مع بال وغيرها فقد تم تاخيرها
وايضا وجود محطه اربع محطات الان متوقفه
عن استقبال القطارات ولا تتوقف فيها
القطارات الامر الاخر هو ان تصريح خطير
لهيئه الاطفاء بان عمليه الاتفاق قد
تستغرق الى غايه يوم غد وبان الاثار
الاخرى لا يمكن التنبؤ بها بسبب وجود خليط
كبير من المواد الكيميائيه ايضا عمال
الاطفاء اجبروا على ارتداء الاقنعه
المضاده للغ وذلك لحمايتهم بسبب وجود خطر
شديد كما وصفته الشرطه على العاملين في
الاطفاء وايضا على سكان المجاور في
المناطق المجاوره الحديث الان هو هو توجه
الرياح لهذه السحابه التي ابادت الان
قريبه من وسط المدينه وهو ما ينذر كما
تقول الشرطه بان تاثيرها على السكان
المحليين قد يكون خطيرا اذا لم يلتزم
السكان بارشادات الشرطه وبارشادات هيئه
الدفاع المدني الخليط الكيميائي الى غايه
هذه اللحظه لا يمكن حصره ولكن ما تم
الاقرار به هو وجود هذا الكبريت كبريت
الهيدروجين وبانه كان ضمن منشاه تخزين في
مستودعات في احدى المحطات القريبه من وسط
المدينه وليست بعيده عنها توجد في شمال
الشرق المدينه وهذا الامر يؤدي في تحليل
الشرطه الالمانيه الى ان
المتسبب في هذا الامر غير واضح لغايه هذه
اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان عن اسباب الحريق
ومن تسبب فيه لغايه هذه اللحظه نعم اشكرك
يا عيسى الطيبي من برلين شكرا